[Music]
[Applause]
Albert Breer senior NFL reporter lead
content strategist for the Monday
Morning Quarterback he is the Monday
Morning Quarterback and he's look at
look at the paperwork here I got on all
of these quarterbacks here this is a
deep dive I mean he even went to uh
Devin Leary at Kentucky in Washington
State's Cameron Ward Deion Sanders son
there's a lot of quarterbacks but we
start with uh Caleb Williams at the top
are there any negatives with Caleb
Williams
it's hard to find one Dan I mean we're
really at the point now where it feels
like this is encroaching on that Andrew
Luck Trevor Lawrence category and I you
know I've been covering the league for
almost 20 years and I think over my
lifetime there are four guys that are
sort of in a different category from a
prospect standpoint at that position
John Elway Peyton Manning Andrew Luck
Trevor Lawrence that doesn't again
doesn't mean
anything as far as what they became in
the league but just how they were seen
coming out of college and I think the
lack of flaws with Caleb Williams and of
course we're going to pick them apart
and he's going to have all the pressure
on him this fall because of that
um but just as far as where they are you
know going into their last year and then
where they should be coming out of their
last year in college that's where Caleb
Williams is and Drake makes really well
thought of too but everybody I've talked
to said there is a gap you know it's
Caleb Williams won Gap Drake May 2
gapping in the pack and so Caleb
Williams is seen that way as the sort of
generational prospect that Trevor
Lawrence or Andrew Luck were over the
last 15 years uh you are joining us here
on vacation and uh we appreciate you
joining us but I'm looking in the
background there you got the water yeah
and there's some there's some kids there
are those your kids
so my daughter's right here okay yeah
okay
I wasn't sure and my kid my I think my
uh I think my my son's trying to make
air by driving as fast as he can by the
shot on his bike yeah I just saw him I
saw him zoom zoom uh by you there but
that picture is real the water is real
behind you there water is real yeah the
boats are real all of it Todd actually
it was Todd hooked me up here and uh we
actually had a less Scenic shot and then
I said well hey how about this so this
was this was actually his choice not
mine I like it I like it you know I'm
not chest pounding or anything else
because for everybody who's out there
thinking I'm bragging my summer is
officially over in about a week so I'm
just kidding what I can get while I can
get it uh give me some other names that
we should keep an eye on this upcoming
season that yes Caleb Williams is one
Drake May would be two and then who's
going to be that third quarterback off
the board
sure like one thing that kind of kept
coming up when I talked to more people
is Bo Nicks at Oregon who you know I
think was seen as a very flawed player
playing in a flawed offense at Auburn
and I think he opened a lot of eyes with
what he did last year at Oregon and
being able to do that again even though
he lost his offensive coordinator and
even though he lost some offensive
lineman in his sixth year in college
this year I think could get him in the
first round discussion and I think he's
a little closer to that than some of the
other guys now there are guys that I
think have more Talent than him and two
of them will be Quinn yours at Texas and
JJ McCarthy at Michigan where those guys
have talent to potentially go in the
first round the question is are they
going to develop like they need to
develop like they aren't finished
products yet
um you know when I Trent Dilfer who you
know like and as you know sees all these
kids from high school on up and has seen
a lot of these guys through the Elite 11
program since they were teenagers said
Quinn yours has like a Jeff George arm
right and I think when you watch Texas
on Saturdays you can see that so so but
yours is still pretty raw so playing
another year for Steve sarkisian in
Texas does he get there where he's the
third quarterback off the board JJ
McCarthy is another one where he was up
and down at points last year but he won
his first 12 starts at Michigan so is he
in the conversation so I think those
three names Nix McCarthy yours would be
in the conversation Jordan Travis at
Florida State's another one and I think
that's what's so intriguing about this
year's classes you've got a clear one
you got to clear too and then you've got
like this clump of players where there's
real talent and they're going to kind of
duke it out for draft position over the
course the next six months I talked to a
talent evaluator this is after the end
of last season and he said he would lump
in Michael penick's and Washington yeah
and and put him in there of and I think
he's been around maybe five years you've
transferred from Indiana but great
sticks
that's the coven thing though like
that's what that's what happens Gordon
Travis is well I I said I think Nix is
five years okay but Jordan Travis is six
years right and pennix is six years and
that's like the covert effect is the
guy's got the extra years of Eligibility
and penix is interesting because I think
he's got some physical ability
but it's sort of like Nick's a little
bit and that like a lot of people didn't
like his Indiana tape and then he went
to play for Caitlyn Deboer at Washington
and I think there's that thing you know
like that that you hear sometimes is it
the offense or is it the quarterback and
Bo Nicks is going to have the
opportunity to answer those questions
this year at Oregon because he's losing
his offensive coordinator who went to
Arizona State to be the head coach the
question is with panics I think it's
going to be a little more of can you
dispel all the questions that he had
hanging over him at Indiana playing in a
little bit of a different type of
offense at Washington but there is some
Talent there and uh yeah he'd be another
one I should have thrown him in the mix
but that sort of tells you how big the
group is too is that there's a half
dozen guys who I think have an
opportunity to maybe play their play
their way into the first round
discussion or at the very least into
like the top hundred discussion what
about Deion Sanders son
yeah so he's interesting because you
know he was a dominant player at Jackson
State and now we're seeing more with
these guys is they have the opportunity
to transfer up and so you know now
you're going to get to see him in the
Pac-12 playing at Colorado
um and you know the word that came up
was Dion's kid was the same word that
came up with Drake May which was smooth
like he looks really natural playing the
position and now playing against better
competition at Colorado we should get a
a look at how he looks when everybody
else has got the same level of ability
that he does because remember he was a
guy who coming out of high school had
the opportunity to play at that level
but wanted to play for his dad and so we
haven't seen him in the context of like
the FBS like power five level and now
we're gonna get the chance to see him do
that at Colorado and we're gonna and the
cool thing about it is we're going to
see him do it at Colorado where in a lot
of games they're going to be at a talent
deficit so NFL evaluators are going to
get the chance to look at him and see
what it's like when he doesn't have a
talent Advantage going against the other
team Albert Breer joining us from
vacation he's the Monday Morning
Quarterback of NFL free agent updates
anything yeah uh I mean I assume you're
talking about the big two which we've
all been obsessing over over the last
month because there's not a whole lot
else to talk about but DeAndre Hopkins
and and Dalvin cook would be the two
um you know I think both their
situations are somewhat similar in that
the money hasn't built what they wanted
it to be and I think the hope is as you
get closer to a training camp maybe a
contender
like looks at its roster in their
pre-camp meetings and says you know we
need to add a body there or somebody has
an injury earlier in Camp and they
decide that they need to act with some
emergency and up the ante a little bit
um you know obviously with hop like the
teams have been Tennessee and New
England and those teams haven't been
willing to go to the financial point
that he wants somebody to go to to get
him
um now I think he'd be willing to go at
a little bit of a discount to a buffalo
or Kansas City but that ship sort of
sailed going back to the draft when you
know the Odell Beckham deal got done and
that sort of poisoned the well on the
negotiations with Hopkins with those two
teams so like for example Kansas city is
in a situation where they gave the money
they were going to give to Hopkins to
Donovan Smith the their new left tackle
and so they decided we still need a body
at receiver they draft froshi rice in
the second round out of SMU so like
coming out of spring now do they look at
it when they have their meetings before
camp and say
we don't want to rely as much on Rice as
a rookie so we need to go and get a uh
DeAndre Hopkins oh by the way if we get
a deal done with Chris Jones that's
going to free up some cap space for us
to do it so I think the Chiefs would be
a contender to get back in there
um Buffalo I think just because the
Stefan Diggs situation I think they'd be
a no
um they were cognizant of that even
before everything kind of blew up in
June
um that like they really had to be
cognizant of where the ball was going
and that Steph needed a certain amount
of touches and Hopkins is sort of a
volume player so I don't think that
they'll get back in it
um you know and then with cook I I still
think the team to watch with them is
legit with him is the Jets
um you know like I I I know he's got an
interest in them and you know looking at
where they are from a roster standpoint
you know bringing um bringing Breeze
fall back from injury and having the
opportunity to be a little flexible as
far as giving him his time to come back
from his ACL and maybe getting him in a
better place in October rather than
rushing him back in September and still
you know doing your best to act with
urgency to win the games in September
because you are in a win Now situation
with Aaron Rodgers would make all the
sense in the world so I think she has to
be the team to watch with cook you know
we'll see what happens as we get closer
to the camp with both those guys if more
contenders throw their hats in the ring
and I know that was a complicated answer
but I'm trying to recap the last three
months with both those guys yeah and I
agree with you on Dalvin cook with the
Jets uh and I thought about Dalvin cook
with the Cowboys with Tony Pollard
coming back from a broken leg that you
know the jets are in an all you know a
win now mode the Cowboys are always in
that and I just think you know the the
contributions of both of those running
backs that you give them a little extra
time instead of kind of you know
Expediting their rehab process and
bringing those guys in but I don't know
what happens when they get healthy and
now you got you're sharing you know
touches and how that works there but it
feels like Dallas
yeah I yeah I mean Dan I think with the
Jets it's like
every game counts now you know what I
mean like not that it doesn't other
teams but like if you're the Jets it's
like no we're in it for now like we're
in it for now we don't know what 2024 is
going to look like what 2025 is going to
look like you know and I think if you
talk to like Buccaneers people they
would tell you we were all in for every
game and it it was the right thing to do
because we competed for championships
for three years and we won one right and
that's sort of where the Jets are right
now so you can't throw away week one or
week two to be judicious with a single
player so if you want to still be
judicious with that single player how do
you make it work well you get somebody
to replace them for those two weeks you
know yeah and so I think that's why that
sets up as sort of a perfect situation
if they could work the numbers out and
again like both these guys
money is a factor with both of them like
those guys aren't going to go take the
league minimum to chase a ring uh before
I let you go and you uh end your reign
as the worst dad ever as you're doing a
live report while your kids are riding
your bikes near the beach there
um I wondered about this with Greg
Popovich he signed a five-year deal
after they get Victor run by Yama in San
Antonio I'm wondering if there's a
quarterback that will keep Belichick
let's say he got Drake May or Caleb
Williams
is there a player that would keep him in
that job almost energize him sort of the
way Victor Juan bayama has done Greg
Popovich
yeah that's an interesting thing I
I don't know because I do think that the
Schuler record is sort of looming over
all this and I I believe he's 19 wins
away which puts you like borderline you
know like based on the team they have
it like it's a toss-up does he make it
there by the end of 2024 and like I
everybody I know that knows Bill really
well says like his juice for the job
hasn't gone anywhere like he still loves
it and he's found a way to balance it
where
you know like I think he can still do
the things that a lot of 70 year olds 75
year olds want to do in retirement and
still be a a coach you know what I mean
and still do all of that and so I you
know I think wins and losses are a part
of it and yeah I mean I think if a
certain level of quarterback came along
or if Mac Jones somehow got to that
level now I don't think most people
would tell you that's in the cards but
if like he had another person at that
another quarterback at that level I
think it would certainly be something
that would be tempting for him to stay
because I do think that like he's gotten
to a point and I'm sure it's the same
with pop where
like all the things you want to do you
know in your golden years like in your
70s and your 80s like those guys have
sort of figured out how to do that and
do the job you know and so I think that
that's like a little thing that like has
made it so to go made it so he could go
from the guy who said you won't find me
out there like Marv Levy yeah in my 70s
coaching to now being that guy you know
what I mean like I think this would
allow them to do it and so yeah I mean I
think if he looks at it and says
I could win two championships in five
years but the quarterback that I have I
certainly think that that would be
something that might that could entice
them to stay and like on paper at least
looking forward at it now like Caleb
Williams and Drake May would be that guy
now the problem is you're going to need
to be absolutely awful yes you know what
I mean like so I don't like if they're
that bad does Robert Kraft keep him
around yeah you know I wondered about
that uh go back to being a great dad
there on vacation I I hope you can find
your children and thank you I bring my
uh I think my attention poor son just
like skidded by yeah I saw him but but I
gotta find your daughter I'm looking for
her in the uh the picture there well
there are three of them I think our
middle may have uh
so thank you Albert all right thanks Dan
that's Albert Breer senior NFL reporter
and he is the Monday Morning Quarterback